[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
herzlichen dank krise einführung und wir
beginnen ja eine vorlesungsreihe oder
vortragsreihe jetzt hier die sich mit
der anthropologie und verhältnis
anthropologie und ethik beschäftigt man
könnte sagen das ist ja eigentlich
irgendwo überholt anthropologie ist doch
erledigt das ist doch keine
philosophische disziplin die man seriös
mehr betreiben kann
einige bekannte philosophen der
gegenwart sind ja nun ausgesprochene
anthropologie gegner zum beispiel jürgen
habermas und viele andere
ich werde jetzt hier heute versuchen
jetzt muss ja nicht überzeugen aber ein
argument zu entwickeln warum man ohne
anthropologie in einem bestimmten
verständnis nicht auskommt und werde
versuchen das konzept dieser form von
anthropologie dass der kritik an der
traditionellen anthropologie nicht
ausgesetzt ist zu erläutern ich werde
also jetzt hier eine these zur
diskussion stellen
kalojew eine normative anthropologie
haben wir das jetzt mal genannt
und das wird sich dann im laufe dieser
vortragsreihe natürlich immer wieder
anders darstellen und ja noch ganz
andere positionen kennenlernen
aber ich denke als auftakt ist es
durchaus sinnvoll das zu versuchen
ich werde also nicht den versuch hier
machen etwa allgemeine informationen
über die entwicklung des
anthropologischen denkens oder übersicht
über die verschiedenen theorie ansätze
hier vorzustellen dass wir eine ganz
andere vor lösung sondern ich möchte
eine bestimmte philosophische auffassung
also meine philosophische auffassung zu
dieser thematik hier erläutern
ich muss mich auch entschuldigen
eigentlich müssen was umdrehen ich setze
mich jetzt hin und lausche ihre
diskussion weil
eigentlich gar nicht reden sollte und
nur mit einem mittel reden kann was man
nicht mehr als drei tage nehmen darf
ohne abhängig zu werden also es wirkt
und ich hoffe es hält an bis zum ende
verfolgen oder zum ende dieses vortrags
also ich beginnen mal mit dem was ich
als sie müsse gelegentlich vielleicht
mal kurz geduld haben wenn es gar nicht
geht ich beginnen mal mit dem was man
vielleicht als traditionelle
anthropologie bezeichnen kann
die viel kritik auf sich gezogen hat
also um einnahmen dazu zu nennen
das ist insbesondere das was man auf das
traditionelle des naturrechts denken
bezeichnet oder das was in zahlreichen
katholischen enzyklopädien eine wichtige
rolle spielen oder in der ablehnung der
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
das weiß rot wie besser als ich in den
beratungen des parlamentarischen rates
also zum beratungen zum zur verfassung
oder dann zum grundgesetz
wo die vier frauen war nur vier
vorgeschlagen haben die
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
aufzunehmen ins grundgesetz und ihnen
entgegen gehalten wurde das sei mit dem
christlichen menschenbild unvereinbar
von ziemlich prominenten politikern der
damaligen zeit und dieses argument war
auch nicht ganz von der hand zu weisen
denn die veränderung der katholischen
kirche zu dieser thematik erfolg erst
mit dem zweiten vatikanischen konzils
1962 bis 1965 in einem sehr mühsamen
prozess und wenn es heute abspaltungen
wie zum beispiel die piusbrüderschaft
gilt dann sieht man wie mühsam dieser
prozess war viele
diese veränderung nicht mitgemacht also
bestimmte anthropologische argumente die
zum beispiel besagen dass homosexualität
sittenwidrig ist jedenfalls praktizierte
homosexualität wenn auch nicht die
einstellung der homosexualität das ist
auch die aktuelle meinung der
katholischen kirche offizielle
lehrmeinung warum weil dies dem
menschenbild widerspricht homosexualität
ist mit diesem menschenbild unvereinbare
und so weiter und so weiter ich habe es
mir mal dieses eine beispiel genannt was
die anthropologie als denkfigur
gewissermaßen in misskredit gebracht hat
will das jetzt an einem anderen beispiel
noch etwas genauer erläutern nämlich aus
der politischen philosophie wenn sie
ältere lehrküche heranziehen
insbesondere aus den 50er und 60er
jahren zur entwicklung des politischen
denkens dann beginnt die darstellung so
gut wie jeder theorie mit römisch 1
anthropologie also zum beispiel jetzt
hier an diesen vier klassikern habs
lockerer so und kanten vielleicht noch
marx ausgeführt beginnt das dann
ungefähr so also wie verstehen wir
untersuchen das menschenbild von holz
das ist die basis
und in der tat die drei lateinischen
publikationen von thomas hobbes sind
auch so aufgebaut die coporate das ist
physik die romane das ist anthropologie
dezibel politische philosophie und das
ganze soll irgendwie systematisch
abgeleitet sein das heißt aufbauend auf
den physikalischen grundlagen macht man
sich dann gedanken über den besonderen
körper mensch einer der beliebten körper
der bestimmte eigenschaften er wird
angetrieben sowie himmelskörper durch
anziehung und abstoßung kräfte sowie
gravitations wechselwirkung etwa oder
elektrostatischen kräfte das ist der
menschen liebe und hass und das ganze
wird gesteuert durch bestimmte
sensorische effekte durch bestimmte
umwelt wahrnehmungen freiheit gibt es
nicht der einzige unterschied den der
mensch zu anderen beliebten körpern hat
ist dass er fähig ist des prospektes
prospectus ist die vorausschau dass der
kann sich urteile bilden über das was
passieren wird und als solcher hat der
mensch als einziges lebewesen angst vorm
tod zum beispiel angst vor seinen
insbesondere gewaltsame tod und dann die
traditionelle anthropologische
argumentation jetzt haben wir das
fundament das anthropologische fundament
und der rest lässt sich jetzt irgendwie
der duh tief daraus entwickeln zum
beispiel der naturzustand in dem die
menschen in einem ballon mini e control
ist gefangen sind oder zweites beispiel
hier jetzt im stenau stil john locke
anthropologie kapitel 1 anthropologie
beiden loks so stets nicht bei john lobb
übrigens noch er wird thomas haupt der
beginnt nicht mit der anthropologie
charakteristischer weise aber die
sekundärliteratur stellt das so da
kapitel 1 anthropologie na ja im
gegensatz zu hawx ist lockt ein er
optimist dass die anthropologie an geht
der mensch erkennt wechselseitig sich
rechte an recht schreibt sich rechte zu
modernen ausgesprochen erkennt an dass
menschenrechte haben unabhängig von
jeder staatlichen ordnung ist auch
bereit sich an diese
rechte zu halten diese rechte also nicht
zu verletzten obwohl er sonst eigene
orientierung sein persönliches wohl
optimiert das führt allerdings ohne
rechtsstaat zu konflikten und endet dann
am ende ebenfalls sind so was ähnliches
mit dem hauptschul bellamy um kontrolle
ist deswegen der staat hat die aufgabe
die menschenrechte dieser drei
kategorien unversehrtheit leben
unversehrtheit und rechtmäßig erworbenes
eigentum zu sichern
also auch da passt es wunderbar wo so
klar die banale version der enzyklopädie
lautet wo so hat ein natur ideal des
menschen
der freie waldmensch der herum streift
und sich gelegentlich mit einem
angehörigen des anderen geschlechts
trifft um nachkommen zu zeugen ansonsten
aber frei und unabhängig bleibt fragt
man was geschichte mit den kindern aber
das ist wahrscheinlich frauensache also
der mensch greift dann der mensch
streift dann weiter einsam durch die
wälder
es gibt sonst keine großen konflikte es
gibt keine egoismen und die frage ist
sie stellt die politische ordnung diese
ursprüngliche freiheit von der in den
kontrast sozial so rhetorisch brillant
redet wieder her nämlich den ceo der
durch die selbstbestimmung durch die
kollektive so frei bleibt wie damals der
waldmensch der durch den urwald streift
das ist die enzyklopädie variante von
rousseau wunderbar anthropologie alles
andere ergibt sich logisch produktiv wir
müssen die prämissen der theorie kennen
dann kennen wir ihre inhalte
ich lasse man jetzt die weiteren
schritte einfach aus ja das kann man so
beliebig fortsetzen
das ist die traditionelle rolle von
anthropologie jetzt gab es so etwas wie
eine quasi naturalistische erneuerung
der anthropologie
ich nenne das quasi naturalistisch weil
ich den hauptvertretern denkt er so an
gehlen plessner auch einige andere nicht
zu nahe treten wird uns vielleicht
fehlinterpretieren will sind sicher
keine naturalist im engeren sinne
aber die grundidee ist schon die dass
die anthropologie unter bedingungen der
zeitgenössischen wissenschaft sich zu
orientieren habe an empirischen
erkenntnissen die spezies mensch
betreffend und dann wird überlegt was
machten das besondere dieser spezies aus
im vergleich zu anderen spezies die es
auf der welt gibt
dazu gehört zum beispiel nach auffassung
dieser quasi naturalistischen
anthropologie das nicht festgelegt seien
die anpassungsfähigkeit an unterstands
unterschiedliche umweltbedingungen und
so weiter und so weiter
das heißt es werden besonderheiten der
menschlichen spezies entwickelt unter
mehr oder weniger engen bezug auf
empirische befunde problematisch an
diesem ansatz ist allerdings die
willkürlichkeit der auswahl dieser
besonderen eigenschaften also will
überhaupt nicht sagen dass die
naturwissenschaft die anthropologie
naturwissenschaftlichen sinne ein
interessantes oder so für relevant sein
das ist nicht die these kommen wir
vielleicht noch mal darauf zu sprechen
vielleicht auch in der diskussion das
verhältnis ist komplex soll ich sagen
zwischen naturwissenschaftlicher
anthropologie und philosophische
anthropologie
aber der versuch die anthropologie zur
wissenschaftlichen indem man sie zu
einer
quasi naturwissenschaft umdeklariert und
versucht gewisse essentially a
empirischer studien zur menschlichen
spezies zurückzuführen das ist eine hoch
dubiose angelegenheit und vielleicht ein
konkretes jetzt ethisch nicht ganz
irrelevantes beispiel zu nehmen wird
unterdessen übrigens auch von thierry
theologen die verhaltensforschung
bezweifelt aber offenbar ist war
jedenfalls lange zeit die überzeugung
von ethnologen dass die angehörigen der
spezies mensch zu den ganz wenigen
gehören die sich unter normalbedingungen
untereinander umbringen
also von den höher entwickelten
säugetieren es ist ein sehr
ungewöhnliches verhalten
das ist sonst praktisch nicht gibt und
jetzt könnte man sagen na gut das müssen
wir mal zur grundlage machen einer
philosophischen anthropologie
das ist ja dann vielleicht besonderes
merkmal was besonderer förderung
bedürfen
ja weil das die menschen aus der
sonstigen natur ordnung heraushebt und
so weiter
also ich lass mal dass mit diesen etwas
unfairen bemerkungen bewenden die
tatsache dass die erneuerung diese quasi
naturalistisch erneuerung der
philosophische anthropologie auch noch
extrem konservativ weltanschaulich
eingefärbt war tat ein übriges um dieses
projekt zu diskreditieren wie letzt drei
hauptkritikpunkte nennen an der
traditionellen anthropologie
ich hoffe die sind ja so ein bisschen
vorbereitet
der erste kritikpunkt den nämlich crypto
normativität also noch mal das beispiel
aus den beratungen des parlamentarischen
rates statt darüber zu diskutieren ob
frauen und männer in einer gesellschaft
gleichberechtigt leben sollten wird
festgestellt
der mensch ist nicht so
ja wir haben ein bestimmtes menschenbild
was dem nicht entspricht aber dieses
menschenbild stützt sich auf befunde die
dem urteil der delegation der abwägung
zum beispiel im parlamentarischen rat
entzogen sind
oder wenn heute noch vom konservativen
gesagt wird homosexualität ist
sittenwidrig
dann wird das damit nicht damit
begründet dass man eine gesellschaft
bevorzugt und der es keine homosexuellen
gibt oder weniger homosexuelle gibt als
heute sondern dann wird das vermeintlich
objektiv gegründet und der rekurs auf
eine wieder natürlichkeit eine eine
praxis die der menschennatur der
objektiven gegebenen menschennatur
widerspreche
das nennen wir jetzt crypto normativität
das heißt statt explizit zu sagen was
einem nicht passt was man ein bisschen
mal was einem den eigenen werten nicht
entspricht und starb diese werte zu
versuchen zu rechtfertigen
zieht man sich zurück in eine
argumentation vor um die in wirklichkeit
normativ ist sich aber und als eine
nicht normative nämlich als eine
feststellung der objektiven menschen
natur und diese argumentation formen ist
alles andere als überholt die ist auch
heute noch in vielen diskursen relativ
stark vertreten
in westlichen
westeuropäischen vielleicht speziell
liberalen gesellschaften weniger stark
als transatlantisch in den usa wo
gegenwärtig diese argumentation formen
erstaunliche renaissance erleben und sie
sind sehr weit verbreitet in kulturen zb
afrikas asiens und so weiter also nennen
wir das ganze crypto normativität zweite
kritik traditioneller anthropologie ist
das was ich als ethischen
fundamentalismus bezeichnen möchte das
ist nicht das gleiche jetzt wie dogmatik
aber es hängt jedenfalls den miteinander
zusammen
der ethische fundamentalismus zeichnet
sich dadurch aus dass er bestimmte
normative positionen der kritik entzieht
das kann natürlich im rahmen von
weltanschauung oder
religionsgemeinschaften am einfachsten
dadurch geschehen dass ein
identitätskern definiert wird der selbst
nicht mehr gegenstand der kritik sein
darf er wird dann dogmatisch also zum
dogma was den dann die identität der
jeweiligen religionsgemeinschaft oder
weltanschauungsgemeinschaft oder der
lebensform usw ausmacht das heißt die
überführung von normativ ethischen
argumenten in anthropologische oder die
maskierung ethisch normativer argumente
in der gestalt von anthropologischen
führt ebenfalls in der traditionellen
form eine top-partie sierung mit sich
dass diese argumente werden der kritik
gewissermaßen entzogen sie werden zum
kern einer normativen haltung gemacht
und das passt dann gut zu dem was ich im
ersten punkt kurz ausgeführt habe das
theorien rekonstruiert werden im
hinblick auf diesen kern
mit diesen anthropologischen kern um den
sich alles andere herum gruppieren muss
umso verständlicher ist die skepsis
gegenüber anthropologischen argumenten
bei denjenigen die sagen die dinge sind
im fluss sie müssen ausdiskutiert werden
in einer liberalen gesellschaft muss die
politische öffentlichkeit delegieren
können diese dinge dürfen nicht im
urteil entzogen werden und was
dergleichen mehr ist das dritte
kritische argument gegen anthropologie
es mit dem zweiten nicht zu verwechseln
wenn ich sein dass es nichts miteinander
zu tun hat man kann das verknüpfen diese
eigenschaften
das ist ein erkenntnistheoretische
fundamentalismus der etwa folgendermaßen
aussieht jede theorie muss systematisch
aufgebaut seien ethische theorien müssen
auch systematisch aufgebaut sein und
dieser systematischer aufbau äußert sich
in der gestalt der aktion tischen
setzung von anthropologischen annahmen
anthropologische annahmen fungieren als
prämisse in einem argument prämissen die
selbst nicht mehr begründung bedürftig
erscheinen also einer englischsprachigen
diskussion wird zwischen fundamente
listen und foundation lesen deutlich
unterschieden da sind auch zwei termine
die da zur verfügung stehen im zweiten
einig fundamentals im dritten punkt 3
meine foundation ist von dessen lösung
heißt wir haben ein fundament von dem
ausgehend die theorie aufgebaut wird das
ist normalerweise ein logisch detektive
aufbauen
die theorie steht und fällt mit diesem
fundament dieses fundament selbst bedarf
keiner rechtfertigung mehr
also der dritte punkt ist ein kritik an
der vom national ist tendenz
traditioneller anthropologie so
anthropologie ist also tot
wir sollten uns von allen
anthropologischen argumenten fernhalten
das ist jetzt die frage deswegen jetzt
ein paar argumente für die
unverzichtbarkeit der anthropologie in
einem bestimmten verständnis über dass
wir dann noch mal reden müssen also wenn
man die anthropologie kritiker sich
ansieht dann spielt für diese eine große
rolle die unterscheidung von regeln und
werden noch mal weil das hier der größte
lebende politische profis und zudem nur
ungefähr 22 kilometer von uns weg lebt
erwähne ich ihnen noch mal also jürgen
habermas
ja das ist dass habermas showprogramm
was eine ganze schule gewissermaßen
eines links liberalismus trägt in der
politischen philosophie und in der ethik
der würde sagen dass der entscheidende
fehler allen anthropologischen denkens
ist dass dort werte zentrale sind
moralität das was sich öffentlich
begründen lässt dass sich der kritik
aussetzen ist worüber man rationale
konsens entwickelt kann in einem diskurs
bezieht sich aber nicht auf werte werte
sind gebunden an spezifische partikulare
lebensformen wurde ja von den schrott
vorher darauf hingewiesen hat ist eine
buchung ein bisschen genauer wird das
verhältnis fotografie und lebensformen
nachgedacht habe also sind gebunden an
bestimmte lebensformen sind von diesen
lebensformen auch nicht ablesbar sind
insofern partikular eignen sich nicht
veröffentliche gar politische diskurse
sind nicht universalisierung
der universalisierung eure bereich
bezieht sich immer nur auf regeln regeln
die wir uns als allgemein etabliert
wünschen und die wir aus der perspektive
jeden diskurs teilnehmers akzeptabel
finden oder sogar rechtfertigen können
unter einbeziehung der jeweiligen
interessenlage der betroffenen in diesem
diskurs so etwa das ist nicht so ganz
präzise wie man meinen könnte bei aber
maß da gibt es verschiedene
interpretationsmöglichkeiten aber so in
diese richtung geht das ich frage mich
ob das funktioniert also man könne ja
sagen dann sind wir ja durch wir koppeln
die politische moralität ab von fragen
der lebensformen und fragen der starken
wertungen lassen allenfalls ganz
schwache wertungen in gestalt der
befürwortung von regeln zu oder
vielleicht allgemein haltungen die diese
regeln zu seinen stützen oder stärken in
der alltäglichen handlungs motivation
aber mehr ist unzulässig
das wird jetzt eine ganz komplexe
philosophische problematik auf die
heimischen sehr lange nachgedacht und so
deswegen ist es vielleicht besonders
schwierig jetzt es in drei sätzen
zusammenzufassen
bei aller sympathie die ich habe sowohl
für diese form des linksliberalen von
habermas wie für die andere berühmte
vielleicht noch einen tick berühmtere
version von john rawls sie funktioniert
nicht es ist politisch einem unglaublich
sympathisch so ungefähr müsste es doch
eigentlich sein
neben einer gesellschaft die leute am
unterschiedliche wertvorstellungen die 1
ebenso die anderen eben anders
verschiedene kulturen gibt verschiedene
identitäten wir können darüber
hinwegsehen
wir einigen unseren auf bestimmte regeln
da gibt es einen rationalen diskurs oder
public reasoning bei broich bestimmten
regeln dieser public riesending prozess
dann einige bei uns und dann wissen wir
was politisch gerecht ist und alles wird
gut es funktioniert mich und ich will
kurz erläutern warum nicht also das
erste ist eine rationale des
theoretischen exkurs also wir haben am
ende ja wie auch immer motiviert
präferenz wir handeln und äußern damit
präferenzen die wir haben in den
seltensten fällen sind handlungen
lediglich motiviert und der rekurs auf
die eigenen interessenlage das kommt mal
vor aber es kommt hauptsächlich in den
lehrbüchern der ökonomie vor nicht so
sehr in der lebensweltlichen realität
das heißt wir haben in aller regel
gründe dafür seine zu tun das andere zu
lassen diese gründe nehmen auch vieles
bezug unter anderem solche dinge wie
rücksichtnahme auf andere
kooperationsbereitschaft gegebene
versprechen und so weiter das kann man
ein bisschen systematisieren man kann
sagen da spielen eine rolle rechte die
andere haben rechte die ich selbst habe
also kategorien rechte spielt eine rolle
die im engeren sinne pflichten die mit
meiner sozialen funktionalität zu tun
hat also eltern lehrer schüler freunde
und so weiter haben in ihrer jeweiligen
rolle bestimmte pflichten die diese
rollen erst konstituieren
wir haben vielleicht allgemeine
prinzipien wie an die diskriminierungs
regeln diesen tiefen die moralität
jedenfalls moderner gesellschaften
eingelassen
auch in meinen augen auch schon antiker
sogar vor klassischer zeiten wie eine
genaues studium der ilias zum beispiel
nahelegt weiß nicht ob es noch viele
weitere kategorien gibt aber das sind
schon einige die immer zeigen die schöne
entkoppelung von regeln auf die wir uns
verständigen und werten die unsere
präferenzen unsere wünsche unser handeln
im einzelnen steuern geht nicht auf und
beides ist unlösbar miteinander
verbunden
wenn man sich die zeitgenosse
entscheidungs und spieltheorie rational
theorie etwas genauer anschaut dann
haben wir da sogar ein relativ elegantes
verfahren
diese verschiedenen prototyps jetzt
neudeutsch pro haltungen für lorenz zu
machen und dann wird handeln jeweils
ausdruck von unterschiedlichen
proposition ahlen einstellungen also
einstellungen die zum beispiel sich
beziehen auf das was ich erwarte was
passiert was sich ereignen wird bei der
systemischen annahmen über die welt auf
der einen seite und meine bewertungen
zum teil bewertungen die auf meine
eigenen interessen bezogen sind aber
nicht nur natürlich noch vieles an man
könnte es auch so sehen manche sagen das
ist jetzt ein merkwürdige verbindung von
aristoteles und entscheidungs theorie
bei der rümelin sowas stand in
rezensionen meinetwegen dann ist es eine
solche verbindung in der tat ich glaube
der aristoteles hat recht die in der
konkreten praxis äußern sich wehrte und
die werte sind eingelassen in die
konkrete praxis wenn diese praxis
halbwegs kurrent ist dann kann man dazu
sogar etwas genau sagen welche werte das
sind wie die abgewogen werden zu ahnden
zu können
das heißt diese saubere trennung das
soll eigentlich jetzt die essenzen
dieses argument und die ontologie und
theologie funktioniert nicht um das mal
an einem konkreten beispiel politisch
vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig
korrekt auszuführen
eine demokratische gesellschaft beruht
auf einer these der gleichen freiheit
der gleichen autonomie des gleichen
respekt
insofern sind alle wie auch immer
verfassten partikularen lebensformen und
kulturen die damit in konflikt geraten
in einem konflikt zur demokratie oder um
es etwas zu konkretisieren
eine kultur in der mädchen zum gehorsam
gegenüber ihren brüdern erzogen werden
und nicht vom himmel gefallen so relativ
weit verbreitet wird ist nicht
demokratie verträglich das heißt man
kann nicht sagen na wie eine kultur ist
halt so und die andere ist halt anders
oder um ein umgekehrtes beispiel aus der
anderen ecke des politischen spektrums
zu nehmen
jemand der seine dorfbewohner in einer
amerikanischen kleinstadt mobilisiert um
der stadtbekannte die stadtbekannte
schulen eg aufzulösen ist nicht
demokratie verträgt und eine
elterninitiative anhänger immerhin 60
prozent in den vereinigten staaten die
die evolutionstheorie aus den
schulbüchern verbannen will ist nicht
demokratie verträgt
das ist eine kleine partikulare
lebensform die glauben an die bibel und
der bibel steht wie das die erde 6000
jahre alt ist da geht es um viel mehr
es geht um die normativen bedinge und
demokratie die so schöne linksliberale
these der sozusagen leichten
verträglichkeit von partikularen und
öffentlichen reasoning öffentlicher
austausch austauschen von gründen und
gegen gründen funktioniert nicht ja noch
viel dramatischer und damit sind wir bei
einer interessanten anthropologischen
frage man kann vielleicht heute sagen so
wie rolls und habe masters tun
wir sind uns
auch alle einig über vom punkt punkt
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
nicht diskriminierung von ethnischen und
religiösen minderheiten und so weiter
und so weiter
wir stecken in die villen recht wir sind
uns doch alle einig doch die discos vor
diskurs formen des zum beispiel der
politischen liberalismus in den usa
wir sind uns doch alle einig dieser
moment mal
wie ist die demokratie entstanden waren
sich da auch schon alle einig natürlich
nicht die demokratie ist entstanden
aufgrund der ethischen erkenntnis dass
es keine herrschaft von natur gibt
das ist eine ethische erkenntnis die
besagte der fürst ist nicht legitimiert
jedenfalls nicht klagepunkt und zu
beherrschen
das war doch nicht der mehrheitsmeinung
soll doch keine kulturelle praxis was
meine these dass menschen ungefähr
gleicher maßen von unfähig sind dass es
von natur keine über und unterordnung
gibt sondern dass die gestiftete sich
die jeweilige kultur und durch die
jeweilige staatsform dass sie daher
rechtfertigungsbedarf thich ist also von
wegen einer harmlosen vereinbarkeit von
lebensformen und öffentlichen vernunft
gebrauch das sind zum teil tiefe
inhaltliche konflikte
jetzt nur noch ein gedanke das ist der
der jetzt hier sich verbirgt hinter
andere biologen kurzfristiger
perspektive
man kann das was ich hier so verdreht im
weitesten sinne aber so ein bisschen
gefährlich und man kommt da unter
umständen falsche schubladen als eine
art mathis tische auffassung verstehen
und zwar indem ich habe einen aspekt des
pragmatismus schon genannt in den
handlungen in der alltagspraxis äußern
sich bestimmte app ist eh mische und
poetische einstellungen die praxis der
prüfstein der ernsthaftigkeit von
normativen und nicht normativen
überzeugung in der praxis offenbart sich
dieses das heißt die praxis ist nicht
nur ein anhängsel die wirklich
abgeleitet die ich mich irgendwie am
rande sondern in der praxis manifestiert
sich das ganze und das hängt eng mit dem
kubismus zusammen
da die praxis als ganze irgendwie eine
einheit darstellen muss die praxis jeder
einzelnen personen aber auch die praxis
in der gesellschaft müssen die dinge so
halbwegs stimmig sein und diese
stimmigkeit annahme verhindert die
schlichten dichotomien das ist fast eine
krankheit der modernen philosophie und
das zum teil auch der modernen
wissenschaft die dinge hängen zusammen
werten und urteilen überzeugungen haben
hängen auf löslich zusammen regeln und
werte hängen unauflöslich miteinander
zusammen
anthropologische und ethische annahmen
und überzeugungen hängen das ist jetzt
die these unauflöslich miteinander
zusammen wir können gar nicht anders als
in unserem moralischen urteilen und in
einem moralischen motivation
anthropologische annahmen zu ex zum
ausdruck zu bringen
es hat eine gewisse wer jetzt
philosophie sich speziell beschäftigt
hat konzern nach das kommt uns irgendwie
bekannt vor
ja da gibt es ja so einen analytischen
kanzian ismus draußen und so weiter da
kann man vielleicht noch mal für die
diese interessieren noch mal darauf zu
sprechen was das damit ob das damit
zusammen nehmen also anthropologie ist
gewissermaßen nicht etwas wo ich mich
entscheiden kann nämlich stellung oder
nicht sondern wir immer schon zumindest
impliziter stellung nehmen
das ist die these die muss ich jetzt
noch ein bisschen inhaltlich näher
erläutern
also vielleicht jetzt kurz zur
charakterisierung dieser form von
anthropologie also das ist eine basis
neuer anthropologie damaligen normative
anthropologie für die hier plädiere die
versteht sich nicht auch nicht insgeheim
auch nicht versteckt als eine bloße
beschreibung von empirischen sachverhalt
sie ist nicht crypto naturalistisch wie
ich es vorher genannt habe sie ist auch
nicht ernsthaft theorie schließt sie
sich nicht dem staaten zug der gegen
mats philosophie an der in erstaunlichen
umfangen naturalistisch geworden ist die
naturalisten die so einen 80er 90er
jahren sollen den usa aufkommen
die reagieren auf die ratlosigkeit auf
die gewisse aporie der der ethik die der
die 70 jahre dominanz des ethischen
subjektivismus ausgelöst hat in den usa
aber auch international dadurch oder
damit dass sie sagen na ja jetzt mal
leute halblang
wir haben doch eine möglichkeit da
wieder eine objektivität hinein zu
bekommen und zwar in der weise dass wir
das gute für den menschen als eine
empirische frage bestimmt ob ude das neo
naturalistischen arguments geht in diese
richtung sagen ja eigentlich weiß doch
ich kann mir noch überlegen was für den
menschen was für den einzelnen menschen
menschlich gesehen das ganze gut ist ich
weiß doch was ich essen muss damit ich
gesund bin ich weiß noch wie ich meine
pflanze behandeln muss damit sie gedeiht
und so weiter und so weiter
das gute für den menschen lässt sich
doch bestimmen nämlich instrumentell es
gibt doch da kriterien gut da kann man
vielleicht ein bisschen streiten was ist
wirklich ein gutes leben nicht aber zum
großen ganzen da gibt's schon
essentially sind gemeinsam
das ist für die die noch mal mit
philosophie sie speziell ich denke da an
peter werden zum beispiel oder richard
beugt und andere neonazis
aber auch so eine apostolische
naturalisten wie philippa food die hatte
sogar diese analogie wunderbar es auch
irgendwie suggestiv sagt man es gibt
dinge für die kann man sagen was für die
gute und gibt dinge da kann man es für
die dinge selbst nicht sagen seine
instrumente also ob der tisch gut ist
entscheidet sich daran aber wir
anständig die meinen zwecken ein
interessen oder den leuten die diesen
tisch gebrauchen dagegen schon bei der
zimmerpflanze ist ziemlich klar was für
die zimmerpflanze gut ist unabhängig
davon was für mich gut ist für mich gut
wenn sie verteuert weil ich mir da keine
sorgen machen wenn ich bereit bin
ob sie verdorrt ja aber für die
zimmerpflanze ist hat er in jedem fall
schlecht und für einen löwen der nicht
hinreichend ernährt ist es das auch
schlecht und so weiter
also gibt es bestimmte entitäten die
haben diese merkwürdige eigenschaft dass
man weiß was für sie intrinsisch gut ist
so ist beim menschen
das müssen wir dann können wir
naturalistisch das ist das
naturalistische anthropologie können wir
anfangen ethik zu betreiben auf der
grundlage dieser theorie des guten
manche notieren dann zum utilitarismus
wie der gebrauch in naturalistischer
naturalistischer denker oder peter
schaar aber um mal einen nicht
amerikaner zu nennen oder in deutschland
olaf müller sophisticated virgin
gewissermaßen fand ethischen
naturalismus
ich sag jetzt mal vergrößern natürlich
was stimmt daran mich ein kunde auf den
neo naturalismus trifft die kritik der
traditionellen naturrechts denkens
wieder zu die dinge sind extrem unter
bestimmt wenn man beugt oder werten oder
andere liest na ja die haben sehr
sympathisches mensch
leute dann kooperativ und wollen
gedeihen pralles sympathisch aber denken
sie mal an einem naturalisten der sich
eher am sozialdarwinismus des späten
neunzehnten jahrhunderts orientiert oder
so der gerade ein bisschen homburg
werdende mechanismus so in unseren fans
so aller botho strauß oder sloterdijk
oder viele andere kleine geister die
sich groß denken
nietzsches tradition ja was machen wir
dann wenn die sagen ja das ist doch
eigentlich das menschliche sich über die
herde zu erheben das mittelmaß unter
sich hinter sich zurück zu lassen
eine heroische entwicklung zu nehmen
jean genet auch so ein idealer
allerdings ist eher linken typs
französischen existenzialisten also ein
bisschen gewalt gehört vielleicht auch
dazu
manche leser als auch im gefängnis zu
gehen
was ist denn mit dem haben wir da
irgendeine ressource dagegen was zu
sagen also das was für was ich hier
plädiere ist kein rückfall in den
naturalismus weder in den traditionellen
naturrechts naturalismus des
katholischen tourismus vor allem noch in
den zeitgenössischen naturalismus
sondern es ist eine genuin normative
anthropologie
mit anderen worten anthropologie
versteht sich als ein teilprojekt einer
normativen theorie des menschen der
menschlichen praxis menschlicher
interaktion menschlichen selbstbildes
und so weiter und untersteht damit den
kriterien der abwägung praktische gründe
was sich so dass ein immer spricht für
das andere mal abwägen wir an bestimmten
modus der abwägung des lebens wirklich
tief verankert den erfindet die
philosophie nichts alter irrtum der und
deren philosophie der letzten 300
jahre als ob sie diese regeln erfindet
sie erfindet die nichts an sie können
sie allenfalls systematisieren
ich hätte vorher mal so einen hinweis
gegeben ob das nicht irgendwie mit dem
kenianischen analytischen philosophie so
aller straßen zusammenhängt na ja so
kann man das auch interpretieren die
metaphysik hat ja erst mal einen sehr
schlechten ruf
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert alle
behaupten von sich keine metaphysiker zu
sein und sind es dann doch wenn man
genau hinschaut und ich würde sagen eine
viel vernünftigere haltung ist die
anthropologie als deskriptive metaphysik
zu verstehen das heißt dass eine
disziplin die herausarbeitet welche
festlegungen wir implizit treffen mit
bestimmten argumenten mit einer
bestimmten terminologie mit einem
bestimmen sprachgebrauch mit der art und
weise begründe austauschen so weiter und
in dem sinne erscheint uns dann die
anthropologie als eine form der
rekonstruktion oder der systematisierung
normativer stellungnahmen damit das
nicht zu abstrakt ist bringe ich nochmal
das gleiche beispiel von vorhin die
kritiker im achtzehnten jahrhundert die
als vorläufer der demokratiebewegungen
dann gesagt haben die herrschaft des
fürsten ist illegitim
warum es legitim weil niemand als fürst
geboren wird weil es keine vorrechte
gibt die gott oder die natur irgend
einer einzelperson gestiftete variante
dazu schon lockt alle menschen sind
eigentum gottes und deswegen
ausgestattet mit individuellen rechten
und wer sich an diesen menschen vergeht
zerstörten eigentum gottes ja kann man
ja auch christlich wänden oder in der
gestalt von immanuel kant den ich vorher
ausgelassen habe alle menschen sind
gleichermaßen vernunft fähig jedenfalls
müssen wir sie als solche ansehen und
das gibt ihnen eine spezifische würde
die fähigkeit autonom zu leben nach
eigenen maßstäben nach eigenem maximen
zu leben diese maximen
zu zu beurteilen dass sie zu
vergleichbaren maximen anderer personen
passen also eine art verallgemeinerung
tests zu unterziehen
das macht die vernunft fähigkeit der
menschen aus das gibt ihnen eine
besondere würde und verlangt von uns ein
respekt im umgang miteinander
das ist natürlich eine form von
anthropologie was denn sonst ist eine
normative anthropologie die sage ich
einfach von natur sind wir so und nicht
anders sondern sie behauptet dass es
gute gründe gibt sich in dieser weise zu
verhalten nicht in der anderen und diese
verschiedenen guten gründe die dafür
sprechen sich so und nicht anders zu
verhalten so und nicht anders zu leben
so und nicht anders einstellungen zu
anderen menschen zu haben soll die
einstellung des respektes wird dann
interpretiert auch als eine
anthropologische einstellung muss er
nicht gleich theorie so gleiche respekt
seine haltung zu anderen eine
anthropologische halt wenn sie nicht
gebunden ist andy partikulare täten der
kultur
diese anbindung jetzt von anthropologie
mit dem geben und nehmen von gründen
macht diese form von anthropologie wie
ich sie es darstellen
ganz im gegensatz zur alten
traditionellen anthropologie zu einer
form der verständigung zu einer form der
verständigung
das heißt die anthropologie ist nicht
mehr wie die traditionelle anthropologie
jeder diskussion erzogen sein im
gegenteil die anthropologie wie ich sie
jetzt hier entwickle ist nichts anderes
als eine repräsentation von einer art
und weise einer praxis des gründe gebens
und gründe nehmen ein teil der
kollektiven und der inter subjektiven
verständigen in diesem zusammenhang
stellen sich dann gut das klingt jetzt
ein bisschen vielleicht hoch gestimmt
aber gelegentlich auch identitätsfragen
wie versteht sich unsere kulturelle oder
politische gemeinschaft
was macht den kern dieser demokratie er
nicht aus gibt es nur individuelle
rechte im sinne von abwehr rechten oder
gibt es auch kooperationen
darüber kann man diskutieren das heißt
diese form von normativer anthropologie
ist mit identitätsfragen durchaus
vereinbar und beantwortet diese
wenigstens zum teil das die probleme
auftauchen balance weil das partikulare
steht und universalität ist mir bewusst
vielleicht einmal der diskussion dann
ansprechen soll damit haben wir die
kurze gegenüberstellung die neue ist
also explizit stadt crypto normativ sie
ist explizit normativen ich crypt und
normativ sie setzt auf die liberation
statt auf dogmatik sie ist core and is
tisch und nicht fundamental ist wohl
eher zum schluss noch ein paar
inhaltliche anmerkungen das ist jetzt
natürlich meine füllung des
anthropologischen projektes ich setze
mich dass das für alle zwingend sofort
überzeugend ist aber das was wofür ich
den letzten zehn jahren in
unterschiedlichen varianten argumentiert
habe ist bis man vielleicht auch um zu
provozieren ein bisschen zuspitzen
lasst die finger von den kanonischen
elementen eines humanistischen
menschlichen fetts bildet wenn unser
kurator am ethik zentrum und außerdem
glaube ich sagen zu können guter
bekannter von mir und bedeutender
vielleicht bedeutet ist der
neurowissenschaftler der gegenwart in
deutschland so mal locker sagt wir haben
jetzt festgestellt wird ein paar
empirischen befunden ist der menschen
nicht verantwortlich ist für das wasser
dann ist das nicht so etwas da kann man
mal schnell klären da schauen wir uns
die experimente an stellen vielleicht
fest ach ja stimmt ja nochmal was
übersehen wir sind ja gar nicht
verantwortlich für das was wir tun
sondern dann steht und fällt mit diesem
befund eine lebensform dann steht und
fällt eine humane lebensform die gesamte
zuschreibung praxis die im übrigen fürs
rechtfertig unverzichtbar ist von
verantwortlichkeit würde wenn ernst
genommen kollabieren
und deswegen gibt es ja bei den
wohlmeinenden vertretern dieser
auffassung die tatsächlich meinen es
gäbe
empirische befunde die das widerlegt
hätten was mit verlaub einfach humbug
ist aber bei denen die das glauben die
fügen dann eilig meistens hinzu naja es
ist sich eine nützliche illusion so zu
tun als wäre es anders womit übrigens
die ganze rechtsordnung normative
ordnungen zu einer art nützlichen
illusion wird also was ich in
verschiedenen kleineren schriften die
ich da noch mal kleine werbeblock er an
die tafel werfe versucht habe so
prägnant wieder möglich auszuführen ist
das ist nicht so dass man da den einen
oder anderen mosaiksteinen da rausnehmen
kann und dann setzt mal was anderes ein
zimmer nicht verantwortlich aber irgend
sowas ähnliches harry frankfurt für die
spezialisten unter ihnen die idee
menschlicher vernunft fähigkeit die idee
menschlicher freiheit die die
menschliche verantwortungs fähigkeit und
menschliche verantwortung sind ganz eng
miteinander verwobene begrifflich und
empirisch miteinander verwobene phänomen
da kann man nicht ausbrechen und sagen
na gut das andere lassen wir mal lieber
stehen vorläufig mal der große move den
wir in der philosophie der letzten zehn
15 jahre haben ist dass sie gesagt naja
gut also die freiheit sich irgendwie
aus aber dann definieren bei autonomie
irgendwie um sodass wir autonomie noch
irgendwie retten können das geht nicht
funktioniert wenn man ein bisschen zeit
haben können wir das noch diskutieren
diese art der korinthen kickerei ja das
herauspicken sagte rosinenpickerei aus
das funktioniert nicht weil diese dinge
eng miteinander zusammen hängen
das ist der chor and is muss also die
normative ordnung die eine humane
gesellschaft trägt ist ziemlich komplex
sie ist meines erachtens heute als eine
ergebnis von erkenntnis zum teil klarer
geworden dass nicht eine zufällige
kulturelle konstruktion dass ein
mühsamer prozess ethischer erkenntnis
seit der antike seiten und in seinem
kern im kern dieses humanismus steht
naja wenn man so will eine art
anthropologie die sich aber bewähren
muss in der art und weise die gründe
ausgetauscht werden
die gründe unter anderem an leighton
unser leben formen leben sinn gibt und
so weiter
diese anthropologischen elemente sind
nicht der kritik entzogen sondern sie
sind seien nur repräsentanten der art
und weise wie wir separieren wie wir
gründe austauschen wie wir gründe geben
wir können uns in einem bestimmten sinne
gar nicht anders sehen als
verantwortlich frei und hinreichend
vernunft fällig es geht nicht anders und
kollabieren die formen des umgangs
miteinander insofern sind diese
anthropologischen prämissen nicht
irgendwelche philosophischen spielereien
die zur disposition von philosophischen
ober seminaren stehen
da kann man alles machen da kann man
auch das fremd psychische bezweifeln wie
das neunzehnte jahrhundert gezeigt
die existenz der außenwelt bezweifelt
geht alles in philosophischen
oberseminar aber nicht mehr außerhalb
und deswegen geht es hier um eine
wirklich ernste frage und die
philosophie muss sich verantwortlich
verhalten und die wissenschaft und nicht
da sozusagen leichtfertig den
anthropologischen kern eines humanen
zusammenlebens in frage stellen das war
die ich hoffe ein wenig provozieren mit
dem fluss und ich freue mich auf die
diskussion dankeschön